Alexus at what point in your life did
you decide you wanted to make films
you've you've been a research and you've
done composing and you've worked with
wave theory and things that are just
beyond my comprehension but what made
you want to go in the direction of
filmmaking well I've always been
interested in filmmaking and I've found
it I've always found it fascinating for
reasons I'd never quite understood but i
am i would read biographies of various
filmmakers the famous directors and so
forth but a point that point came in my
composing where I thought well I've got
an unusual approach to composition so
I'm I'm combining kind of elements of
science and technology with elements of
art and I began to think I wonder if
this could be used in a film because
I've always loved film I've always wants
the chance to make a film but can you
really do that can you because all of my
compositions and the you know they
happen lives they have some elements as
subatomic particles and a violin live or
making waves in a wave pool turning to
music live film isn't a live medium you
know film is fixed and you show it and
then it it was about two years ago or
maybe a year and a half ago that I
thought why does it have to be a fixed
medium why can't it actually change why
can't you have a film that changed while
people are watching it and it was at
that point about a year and a half ago
that I actually thought I really could
make a film here because it's my desire
to make a film coming at the same time
as my realization of how my unique skill
set could bring something new to making
a film what would you advise other
people who are professionals in one
arena of their life and then later on
decide to maybe not switch careers
entirely but add something new to their
plate how do they begin how do they
compartmentalize their life well uh so
that's a very interesting question
actually
is I there's been kind of two situations
there was obviously that situation with
making a film and at the point of
deciding to make a film it took a bit of
a leap of faith really it was a kind of
I can do this if I get the right team on
board with the music that was a bigger
decision because that had been something
running in the background through my
life since my early teens and it was
only when I was in my mid-thirties that
I I decided I've got to change you know
I was working on Wall Street and I know
I I had the best job I could've imagined
having and then I actually switched to
working for a start-up but I've and you
know trying to become rich through a
tech startup
but the point came when I thought this
I'm I'm not starting my new career I'm
not I knew I wanted to write or do music
I knew I wanted to do something more
creative and it wasn't happening I was
trying to be a singer-songwriter I was
trying to compose electronic dance music
you know trying to come up with that
magic disk that I could then release to
the world to show what I could do and
somebody would give me the platform or
the money or the the the way to do this
and it wasn't nothing was happening and
I wasn't sure what to do and then I
thought I've got to change my life I
have to change I can only change my
career if I change my life and so I am I
I thought well what could I do
well what I've written was gonna do is
do a music degree this is where luck
comes into it as well good fortune if
you want to call it I said I want to do
a music degree that'll make a big shift
and then I couldn't get on the music to
grow wanted to because they were moving
it down the country too far away I
didn't want to travel I searched at a
closer university and by chance I saw
they had a PhD in computer music
available at the University in my town
there's there's not that many computer
music research groups around the country
in the UK
so this is the good fortune coming into
it and and of course starting on a PhD
you start much higher up the ladder and
in computer music composition is often a
very strong element in the academic
study so I decided I'm going to stop
this job that I'm doing which was the
best paid job I'd ever had and I'm going
to divide my salary to a third of its
current value I did have a little help
I must admit from my family so I had
some family help but not a huge amount
just a small amount and and I started at
the bottom again it wasn't quite the
bottom cause it's a post-grad degree but
it was starting again and that was the
big decision was was being willing to
lower the salary and and start again
you